Read Bell Hooks and then get
back to me it's not my job
to educate you.
I'm a black woman.
Then you'll love Bell Hooks.
You've participated in a
trolling cliche.
(laughing)
- Milton.
The homework giver.
This is when a troll can't
be bothered to explain
why they disagree
with a given post
so they outsource the argument.
"Read this article
then get back to me."
"You should go to
your local library
"and check out a copy
of such and such book
"by fill in the blank author."
"If you haven't seen
the haven't seen
"the brilliant
documentary blah blah blah
"you're really not
equipped to have an opinion
"on this issue."
Hey, thanks teach!
Who knew you were so good and
reading and watching stuff
that tells you how
to feel, you nerd?
Here we've been all
wasting our time
forming our own opinions
like a bunch of novices.
Listen, school sucked
the first time around,
and homework was probably
the number one reason.
Nobody's looking for extra
credit assignments on Facebook.
So unless you have a link
to the Cliffs Notes version
of the article that you skimmed,
please proceed
directly to detention.
Ass dismissed.
(laughing)
I said ass, not class.